let's do some slightly more complicated
fractional exponent examples so we
already know that if I were to take 9 to
the 1/2 power this is going to be equal
to 3 and we know that because 3 times 3
is equal to 9 this is equivalent to
saying what is the principal root of 9
well that is equal to 3 but what would
happen if I took a 9 to the negative 1/2
power now we have a negative fractional
exponent and the key to this is to just
not get too not to get too worried or
intimidated by this but just think about
it step by step just ignore for the
second that this is a fraction and just
look at this negative first just breathe
slowly and realize okay I got a negative
negative exponent that means that this
is just going to be 1 over 9 to the 1/2
that's what that negative is the cue for
this is 1 over 9 to the 1/2 and we know
that 1 to the 9 to the 1/2 is equal to 3
so this is just going to be equal to 1
this is just going to be equal to 1/3
let's take things a little bit further
what would have what would this evaluate
to and I encourage you to pause the
video after trying it or pause the video
to tried negative 27 negative 27 to the
negative 1/3 power so I encourage you to
pause the video and think about what
this would evaluate to so remember just
take a deep breath you can always get
rid of this negative in the exponent by
taking the reciprocal and raising it to
the positive so this is going to be
equal to 1 over negative 27 to the
positive 1/3 power and I know what
you're saying hey I still can't breathe
easily I have this negative number to
this fractional exponent but this is
just saying what number if I were to
multiply it three times if I multiple so
if I have that number so whatever the
number this is I were to multiply it I
took three of them and I multiplied them
together if I multiplied one by that
number three times what number what
would I have to use here to get negative
27 well we already know we already know
that 3 to the third
which is equal to 3 times 3 times 3 is
equal to positive 27 so that's a pretty
good clue what would negative 3 to the
third power be well that's negative 3
times negative 3 times negative 3 which
is negative 3 times negative 3 is
positive 9 times negative 3 is negative
27 so we just found this number this
question mark negative 3 times negative
3 times negative 3 is equal to negative
27 so negative 27 to the 1/3 this part
right over here is equal to negative 3
so this is going to be equal to 1 1 over
1 over negative 3 which is the same
thing as negative as negative 1/3